our favorite Pokemon games looking back
through the archives we have not done
this in the lobby before it seemed it's
like you know getting toward the end of
the year pokemon sun moon is out a lot
of people played it I played about 10
hours jqr much farther than I am I think
yeah I don't think I'm much further than
you but I'm probably like 5 or 6 hours
ahead but this is a difficult question
because are we talking about the games
in general or like the Pokemon
introduced the favorite Pokemon games so
just the the Pat is in one we can get
into all this stuff but like right now I
just want I want to know what your
favorite Pokemon game is pokemon snap
don't try that you know what I'm asking
don't do this right now I don't need you
derailing this Justin comes on you're on
time today though that was nice
I know cuz you keep whining about it
yeah because you don't leave on a tight
ship I don't like it I never know what
I'm gonna come on we've got a tight ship
right here next to the table anyway that
ship is tight if I had to pick one
overall Pokemon game and I don't think I
don't think it's the best in terms of
like historic where it stands now
pokemon yellow is my all-time favorite
game it's like at the time I probably
put more time and like more love into
that game I think the games that have
come after it whoo and of course made it
better it there's a better series in
franchise now than it is than it was
back then but I think pokemon yellow is
one you can still go back to you yet
Pikachu following you around like that
was the first time they can change the
game that was my favorite part if you
made him happy you could turn around
look at him he has little hearts coming
out of his head yeah he I don't know I
actually never I never like finished
yellow I just played red and blue both
obviously okay this is obvious for
anyone who's played Pokemon but
obviously there are like several
versions of each generation for each new
like Pokemon entry just encourages you
like specific Pokemon to one version by
whether it's a legendary or just random
ones like Vulpix or nine tails and blue
as a Porno yeah blue as opposed to like
red which had growlithe growlithe and
arcanine and them if i'm pronouncing
Arcanine yeah it just encourage you to
trade between them but yeah i would have
to say like mines that generation as
well but specifically blue that was just
the one I started with I saw this is
like obviously like like many people
made introduction of Pokemon I saw
squirtle on the front cover
Blastoise so my favorite Pokemon ever
because it's [ __ ] giant tortoise with
water cannons on its shoulders it's like
I want like the next tighten and tighten
fall to that they introduced me blast
sick anyway I'm thinking about titanfall
too way too much lately
so were you disappointed when they
rerelease them and it was
firered/leafgreen and not like an aqua
blue or something
well yeah why why was that like I dunno
I never play them in Japan right they
didn't have blue they had Greek green to
green and red and then blue and red here
and then I guess for that they just went
with the green version leaf green
firehead
yeah then there's omega sapphire and
alpha alpha sapphire alpha sapphire was
the 3d versions of the that generation
correct yeah and like I like those ones
as well but I don't know I still get
such like crazy nostalgia I didn't
realize how much I played Pokemon until
like years later when like X&Y came out
thinking back about how much I played
blue was like holy [ __ ] I played a lot
of that game between just I remember
like that was back when I think Pokemon
games are actually still pretty tough
like whether it was finding your way
around the world or the actual like like
trainer fights gym the badge fights I I
don't know X&Y I didn't have any trouble
at all Pokemon moons a little bit
tougher at some parts but I mean I think
it's more you know you go into an area
and you know exactly what kind of
Pokemon you're gonna be fighting it's
like automatically arranged around you
know fighting pokemons fire pokemon
water pokemon you know what you're going
up against and obviously like if you're
going up into a like I've watered like
against a bunch of water pokemon you're
you know FINA Sora's gonna do pretty
well being the rock-paper-scissors or
weakness for them the early games
weren't always hard for the right
reasons though either like it you know
sometimes hard just figuring out where
am I supposed to go now I'm totally lost
it's like hey like one line of dialogue
that would be like oh then you need to
take this here and you just get past it
on accident and then you'd be like okay
now where do I go and you'd have the
whole map open you'd be like basically
just wandering on aimlessly talking to
people hoping something would trigger
what was the what was the cave you have
to go through in the dark
rocket on a rock tunnels talk about this
yesterday with John hated a dreaded
getting to that whenever you played like
the first time I did that like I was 7
at the time whatever six and like
that took me that must take me like a
week to get through that as like a
little kid like yeah just bumping
against the walls trying to figure out
where I'm going and finally it feels so
good we make to the end though
what was that can't you go back through
didn't you get something that would show
you around like us you can get flash
yeah back when you have TM after you get
through the rock Tom all right 15
because it was a TM it wasn't even HM
bad so it was like basically just go F
yourself into this out so did you try to
did you keep a separate Pokemon around
that you just like piled all of the
crappy moves on a TM like dumpster I
used to I don't anymore because there's
less of that in Pokemon moon and well
Pokemon moon gets ready yeah the right
picture so you just oh right yeah yeah
what everyone yeah could you call a
tourist that busts through rocks and
then Lapras to like go over water and
everything yeah pokemon red blue yellow
obviously like as my introduction than a
lot of people's to the series that's
though my fondest memories I think
although uh second generation which I
think you said was your favorite Jake
silver gold yeah I think I mean I played
more firered than I think of any of the
Pokemon games just because by the time
that came out I was like a little bit
older and I like kind of understood what
I was doing and I had like a team that I
loved you know like right you Pidgeot
Charizard but anyway but I think yeah
that's total [ __ ] but I think one of the
coolest things about gold and silver was
that once you completed those once you
got those eight badges you went back to
Kanto and you had to get the eight
badges from the original and like that I
thought that was incredible like at the
time yeah almost I was disappointed when
sapphire came out because I was like
alright when I finished this am I gonna
go back to another region and then you
don't and then you don't in any of the
other ones yeah so I'm not entirely sure
why they decided to do that for just
that generation but I think that is why
it's my favorite is just because there's
so much to it it was almost like you
know link to the past you think you
finished the game and you go to the dark
world there's a holy [ __ ] there's like a
whole nother second half to this game
except you'd already it was like
recalling red blue yellow yeah but it
like counted is like postgame like I
remove the credits would roll after you
beat that and like alright I'm done and
then like I forgot
gives you a ticket or something but you
go to vermilion City and then it's like
basically remix of Breton features and
fight the gym leaders in different
orders then you fight the Elite Four
again eventually it was your starter and
silver and gold your first one cyndaquil
it's gonna cyndaquil Chikorita who's a
thorough denial
Totodile yeah my was Chikorita just
because i had a helicopter on its head
and because i like remember all my
friends were picking everything but
Chikorita i don't know what's your
favorite starter pokemon in general
outside of pikachu and pokemon yellow
yes Charmander yeah but really it's a
fire dragon yeah buts squirtle is cooler
squirtle I wish squirtle could wear
sunglasses in the games too then I'd
probably fix score like he does in the
show yeah yeah he deserves just a couple
of ray-bans they ordered I typically go
for the fire pokémon like that's that
Pokemon Sun and Moon is probably the
first one where I I went with the green
what I went with the the grass pokemon
yeah well traditionally the fire one's
supposed to be the hardest one as you
fight the water post normally yeah you
fight like in red blue you fight rock or
whatever stem and water wear it but I
don't think it matters at this point
anymore but for a while like red was
hardest her fire was hardest grass was
easiest blue was yeah in moon at least
I'm having no trouble with the grass
pokemon I picked Rowlett sorry Rowlett
and then dart tricks and then I don't
even have a third evolution yet I know
what it looks like but it's pretty cool
but yeah I mean I I think again blue is
my favorite pokemon game so when i
played most the one i haven't like
fondest memories of i do except for like
rock tunnel [ __ ] like that i do not like
that kind of stuff but i do i want to
talk about X&Y because i actually that
was my reintroduction to the series
after i stopped with like silver gold
then i went back to play like a lot of
previous generations and X&Y
again it was the 3d that was pulled me
back in so that was just I loved seeing
like
more nuanced battle animations I loved
like exploring a 3d world I was you know
it's like it's not necessarily 3d in
that game you're still moving on like
four directional axes from what I
remember as opposed to a Sun and Moon
where you actually can just free roam
right Sun and Moon is the first one that
gives you any
of that that completely free movement
like it's like diablo 2 as opposed to
Diablo 3 kind of the same thing you can
just move 360 degrees and a Pokemon Sun
and Moon but I really did like X&Y I
like the new Pokemon um it was a hockey
the the luchador Hawk something similar
like he's the best one you don't talk
about the hawk that I know you talk
about I don't remember it it looks like
a bird of war from my sunny reference
for the day wrestling episode after the
second generation Pokemon I stopped
remembering their names like they just
don't stay in my head anymore
that's I mean that's another reason that
I think I love the original one so much
because 150 felt like a good number then
so like silver and gold came in I'm like
well okay there's there's a lot of
repeats but I can I I can get attached
to these but then it just keeps adding
more and more and I just never bother
true but like there's a couple little
standout bio trubbish I remember I
remember the trash Pokemon it was
hawlucha by the way not her achi cuz
then you ended up like halfway through
X&Y you got one of the other star Depot
starter Pokemon right because I I
started with a chespin and then I got
Blaziken the third evolution of the fire
Pokemon and then you know you get
Lucario and then you get the legendary I
really liked X&Y that was that was the
first time a while I got really excited
played Pokemon game most 2013 I believe
so it's been about yeah it's been three
years now since the last one and that
was my reintroduction to it now I want
to go back I want to play like alpha
sapphire Omega Ruby and those are good
yeah just to relive that was kind of
like the early glory days I don't know I
think I well I'm not looking well I
don't know if it's not that I'm not
looking forward to it but I I guess next
remake they do is diamond and pearl and
those games were like I didn't play
those I have friends who say that
they're their favorite but I don't
remember enjoying that one much at all
like so I didn't play diamond and pearl
I did platinum and I thought platinum
was really good okay so how is that
different than it's not that different
it was just a really solid entry it did
the right thing maybe it's black and
white that I'm thinking of
I can wait or deaf are not my favorite
guess it's black and white then there's
crystal and your black and white - yeah
yeah that was weird - how they did a
sequel to it just chill out just move on
I've been playing Pokemon move
joining it again I'm about like ten
hours in I don't like you mentioned like
talking about your favorite setting like
favorite map I like a Lola just because
it's pleasant and there's not a lot of
conflict outside of these Pokemon
fighting and it's just a nice like the
music's like pretty calming I don't know
do you guys have a favorite map in
general like I'm gonna eye now that we
talked about Rock Tunnel I can't stand
even though it's like burning the back
of my mind how to get around yeah you
know you can fast travel with I really
liked Owen yeah I know people
complaining that there's too much water
in that one but I thought that was a
pretty cool one you can't have more
water than a Lola was a lot like you
actually don't end up surfing that
reaction that was suck you did like a
Wind Waker thing or like I you just need
to get to the next Island good luck
you'll it'll get through yeah there's
what Paris in X&Y what they call that
I remember what it was called in Kalos
Kalos skill yeah Kalos you you actually
go under the Eiffel Tower in the center
of the map
yeah and I've I never played like black
and white I never played crystal and
ever played emerald or any of those I I
want to go back and play a lot he's when
I have time because like so many of them
I think like all from around the 3ds
eshop now right mmm or at least a vast
majority I don't think why yeah probably
actually huh you can play them on your
3ds at least I know that sure yeah yeah
and then I gotta go back nothing current
3ds you can't you can't play games on
ODS you can I saw emerald and Lord oh
yeah because you get but you can get
Omega sapphire yeah Omega 2 right those
were like that was last year I believe
yeah I don't know maybe I'll go back and
play those cuz I kind of I'm like trying
to search through my minutes nostalgia
for the good parts now that I'm thinking
like Rock Tunnel and like Pikachu
following me around which I didn't like
I'm not as big of Pikachu fan as most
people it's a again I was in Japan
recently and like this is not news to
anyone but like he's like the Mickey
Mouse of Japan like he is everywhere
lucky for you where I got here like you
just walk around and there's like a
Pikachu follow yeah I you know I saw one
getting mugged in an alleyway no I'm
just kidding
it was very like a safe city from what I
saw of Osaka
but know it like we're just sitting in
these random like bars and I look over
and there's Pikachu just comes in a
corner you're very fixated on this real
Pikachu coming up he serves me a drink
like I get it I guess people like the
really big Pikachu costumes just comes
up electrocutes you yeah like an actual
Pikachu in the wild in Japan anyway yeah
that was our just want to talk more
about the series in general because
again your Pokemon Sun and Moon review
is up even 8:00 at 10:00 you go read
that on GameSpot calm let us know what
you think about Pokemon Sun and Moon let
us know what your favorite pokemon games
are or is let us know your favorite
setting is favorite starter pokémon
squirtle the only real answer but anyway
leave your thoughts in the comments
below